many things wrong with me is this
property hotter if it comes with a
squatter this real estate listing
includes a tenant with no lease so after
you buy it you probably have to call the
police a virginia home is already under
contract after a few days on the market
after being listed for 800 grand in cash
with the stipulation that the owner will
not be able to even see the downstairs
because there's already another person
living there with no lease
cash only plus a mystery tenant this
sounds legit
the listing was very clear that the five
bedroom three bathroom home needs about
25 grand in renovation as there are
issues such as a broken dishwasher and a
toilet that is shut off because it leaks
to the lower level oh this sounds like
the ritz carlton
in mogadishu
anyway it is not clear if the person
living there is a previous owner or a
squatter but who knows it may be a hot
chick
a sexist would say
my mistake could be a free loading
relative
who's also a hot chick huh oh sexist
would say
okay fine either way you should never
make real estate decisions based on
whether there's a hot chick living there
unless she's got a rack
oh sexist would say i wasn't finished
that was a rack of really wonderful
spices
and a nice ass
a sexist would say
a petting zoo with a little donkey all
right
jimmy i couldn't end that segment so we
just kept it going
theory
well first of all it's nice to see
someone buying a house besides black
lives matter i think that was nice uh my
theory for real i know my theory for
real is that i think the ad is fake and
i think it was made to go viral because
everyone reacts to something like this
no no no that's just i'm not done okay
but that's where i started is i think i
actually think it was fake but i do
think there's a peep there's people out
there that would buy this anyway i think
the person who actually bought it has an
interest in probably reality tv because
there's something to be accomplished
here by having the mystery person you
know they have the masked singer yeah
you have the masked tenant or whatever
the hell it is you know i think there
might be there might be a story i i
was sean let me hear your theory oh this
guy's a quitter oh yeah
what an unbelievable opportunity to just
go head to head with a tenant in your
basement
and he's just packing it in like this
800k and he's calling it a day
[Laughter]
no way i love how every every story so
far is if only i was there i would have
fought the tenant i would afford the
tenant and the mailman you gotta get
creative this guy's gotta get creative
yeah he's got an unbelievable
opportunity and he's just letting it go
yeah he could have turned it into
something fun yeah this is a great idea
thank you yeah
i don't know how i didn't want to speak
up but unmasked tenant yeah like the
mass singer that's actually actually as
a tv show is a great idea yeah about it
almost as good as some of the shows i've
pitched you know tyrus my theory is that
it's the adult child of uh parents who
couldn't get him out and they figured
this would get him out finally if they
just sold the place with him in it
that those are all nice and touching
theories
i just watched this really disturbing
netflix uh documentary about just these
situations
if you're willing to just sell the house
and leave and leave the person in there
that means you pretty much ran out of
everything because you can't touch them
like the the laws i saw like you could
if you would have went down and like
because my first response would have
been to grab him and throw his ass out
the house then the police would have
come and took and arrested me out my
house and he would have been able to go
back in if they have mail that can be
delivered once mail is delivered to the
house they've established residency and
it's easy for apartment complexes and
stuff to evict people because they have
lawyers and they have all these they
have all the paperwork and stuff but for
private citizens it is a lot of
paperwork and takes it can take up to a
year to evict somebody so this has been
a battle forever and they try and the
document they tried one lady threw a
party every night
every night a weed smoking party every
night to try to get rid of this guy and
they ended up getting in a fight and she
ended up getting kicked out of her own
apartment and he hit her with a
restraining order this we're seeing a
lot of this it's it's one of those
stories where you want to laugh but
because of the pandemic one of the
things was you couldn't evict anybody
and a lot of squatters really took
took advantage and this is what
desperate people are doing now they're
throwing he probably didn't i mean 800
000 is great but you know i don't know
what the actual value of the house is
but it's it's sad that they work they're
just throwing they're throwing their
hands up because you can't even
old fashioned go down like the only good
thing in that story i heard is that the
toilet was leaking yeah i would have
drilled a hole in every toilet in my
house and left my showers on none of the
toilets were working cat
but anyway that's not my that's not a
question
it could be though why are none of the
toilets working
what's your theory
look it can be really it's it can be
hard to get someone out of your living
space if you look
you sound like either you were on one
side of that equation i was on the side
of the person paying for it and
there was someone who's saying you
remember i remember it wasn't someone
who was hanging around my living space
and you know at first it was like okay
he cleans
but i hated him
and
i tried to kick him out so many times
but there was always an excuse like i
twisted my ankle at my shift at abc
kitchen and now i can't leave it was
always something but i eventually did
get him out how did you get him out
um
i just i i really wouldn't let him make
excuses anymore but it went on for for
months really yeah and then he got
waters whirled in
good job
well done jesse oh god he was like when
are you coming home i'm like why are you
in my home
oh you're not my boyfriend
he wasn't my boyfriend but he did live
there now that is that's the most
bizarre thing i've ever heard was he a
friend no okay
yeah she used to explain this okay
every night for like a week
let's just cancel the rest of the
segments
i'm now a healthy person and i don't do
stuff like that anymore all right i
heard of stray cats but straight people
yeah great people he was a straight
person
i met him
i met him at the stumble and things just
escalated
all right there were some raccoons hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else